la réalité virtuelle peut nous faire
croire un monde parallèle mais notre
organisme lui n'est pas dupe il peut
réagir en causant une variété de
cintheaux à lors du bref un confort
jusqu'à des nausées et des
étourdissements prolonger ce mal de la
réalité virtuelle ou cyber malaise avec
plus de la moitié des utilisateurs une
équipe montréalaise suggère une façon de
s'y attaquer
[Musique]
ces personnes s'apprêtent à entrer dans
un monde parallèle un monde qui trompera
leur sens
cet univers c'est la réalité virtuelle
[Musique]
si les premières minutes plaisent
l'immersion n'est pas toujours si
amusante
il arrive parfois qu'elle s'accompagne
d'effets secondaires à divers niveaux la
moitié des utilisateurs en sont affectés
chez certains c'est du sérieux
on parle de symptômes qui s'apparentent
au mal des transports étourdissements
troubles de vision des orientations
nausée cette réaction les experts l'ont
nommé cyber malaise le mal de réalité
virtuelle c'est le fait que ce que je
vis comme comme expérience c'est pas
bien alignées sur ce que
physiologiquement en position passées
une statique
je vis donc ce gentil dissonance entre
ce qui se passe dans le monde virtuel
dans le monde réel
ces réactions physiologiques donne des
migraines à l'industrie plusieurs
chercheurs tentent donc de les résoudre
leur approche est logique
ils ont d'abord cibler les visiocasque
on améliore son confort ont modifié
l'environnement virtuel projeté rien à
faire
les cyber malaise persiste si on règle
les problèmes associés à ce qu'il génère
ce mal de réalité virtuelle est une
industrie qui parviendra pas à réaliser
les attentes que
qu'on pense que la réouverture pas nous
amener aux gros consommateurs
visiocasque environnements virtuels non
pierre majorité j'y crois que la
solution se trouve ailleurs c'est plutôt
d'utiliser ce qui se passe dans le
casque on veut tu dises que la personne
ne vit comme expérience et en utilisant
un siège qui est parfaitement
synchronisé aux stimuli loup félix se
prêtent à l'expérience
il participe à une simulation la pose
d'électrodes permettra d'obtenir une vue
imprenable sur le non-dit sur ces
réactions physiologiques c'est d'aller
mesurer les réactions automatiques et
inconscients du participant celle qui
sera pas vraiment capable de nous dire
après l'expérience
[Musique]
par exemple la moiteur de ses mains pour
cerner le problème du mal virtuel ce
paramètre est important c'est un signe
caractéristique du système nerveux
sympathique celui qui produit de
l'adrénaline et de l'excitation
les images présentées dans le
visiocasque lui indique qu'il est en
mouvement en pleine action normalement
son corps serait immobile tout le
contraire du monde virtuel dans lequel
il serait plongé cette incohérence
sensorielle tout son corps lutterait
contre elle mais le siège dans lequel il
prend place bouche suit ces mouvements
cela changera-t-il la donne
on veut savoir les chercheurs surveille
son rythme cardiaque
si louis félix lutte contre cyber
malaise
il s'efforcera instinctivement de calmer
sa respiration
cet effort modifiera donc sa fréquence
cardiaque d'une façon spécifique sa
respiration est normal idem pour son
rythme cardiaque
'l'indice de sueur dans ses mains en
revanche grimpe en flèche
une excellente nouvelle on observe
vraiment que le mouvement non seulement
il ya un effet pour réduire le mal de
rester virtuel mais il y aussi un effet
pour rehausser l'expérience de réalité
virtuelle
on comprend mieux ce que la personne vit
vraiment en expérience et en trouvant
des alternatives qui sont pas dans le
casque mais dans le reste de
l'expérience vécue il ya probablement
des solutions des pistes d'avenue qui
vont tenter d'élargir le chargeur
[Musique]
voilà peut-être la solution qu'attendait
l'industrie
parions qu on la mettra rapidement à
l'épreuve car le temps presse
les experts prévoient que le marché de
la réalité virtuelle décuplera d'ici les
cinq prochaines années on veut donc un
monde virtuel sans malaise réel
[Musique]